I just want to show you some pictures
here from the woman woman's March that
some of these you can't show on other
shows that's why I really want to show
this but there was it did anyone go to
the woman's March this Wow
very interesting and they marched all
across the country and some of them had
some very funny signs I love this one
Obama are you coming home assume the
babysitter is weird anything you can do
I can do bleeding a woman has a real
Melania ho de ho kill that John in his
sleeve
[Applause]
embrace yourself I've saved the best for
last but this is an older woman look at
hers I'd called Trump a but he
lacks depth and warmth so but you gotta
love Donald Trump he's nothing if not
thick he tweets out beautiful weather
a perfect day for all my hearts
celebrate the historic milestones he's
talking about his economics that has
taken place lowest female employment in
18 years this idiot thinks they're
celebrating him well we actually found
there was a small Enclave in the March
of from supporters he did win white
women in the election so would you like
to see some in their signs these are
these are no these are the women who
actually like Trump a proud female
graduate of Trump you see this
Democrats are dildos I want a real
pricks
the news is faker than my orgasm I like
big butts and I cannot lie
taking back the country we originally to
wife number four Trump may not be a
woman who knows what it's like to have
two boobs and of course cat ladies need
grabbers all right